buongiorno a chi vuoi mangiare a
colazione dolce una colazione strada tra
una colazione americana la frazione
italiana ciccio riccio e uomo ammazzato
io sono juventino di questo video solo
venire comunque difficile trovare una
spremuta giusto per dirlo moscow news la
sicura lungo e molto maestra ok
aspettiamo che ci arrivi la colazione ci
possiamo dare un sacco di abbracci
pronto praticamente primo piano ciao
secolo le grazie mille mi sento in colpa
di uno per terroristici
i lavori vedi io ho detto mi sono
stancato di rifiuti dal balcone usa
prende al volo
ciao ciao busto io c'è questa qui ma mi
intimorisce alquanto è sta roba qui è
tutto quanto di burro a me piace molto
di più quelli che possono essere nostri
di burro mettono la crema al formaggio
assaggia presenti che è immangiabile
zucchero il burro non voleva questa
parte neppure tempo che se vera questa
ma che ora cioè c'è qualcuno a cui piace
faustina burro soprattutto se ci sei
ancora tutti i denti di lavoro non ha
deluso spero di rifarmi nicolò pranzo
ciao ragazzi buongiorno bentrovati un
nuovo video allora io passerò questi tre
giorni a milano e ho pensato dal momento
che stanno spesso a casa di fare un test
io sono il solito ordinare un sacco di
cibo da asporto resi a sushi che siano
hamburger sia sushi uscito sushi uscì un
po di meno la pizza perché sto per dire
una cosa orribile non sono un fan della
pizza avrà aspetto come minimo commenti
di odio però quello che pensa di fare la
seguente cosa quando ordino tendo
solitamente a risparmiare e questo ha
portato ad avere comunque una percezione
particolare il cibo da asporto o che il
cibo trasporto e comodo che non ti muovi
ma che comunque ha una qualità media in
questi giorni però ho deciso di ordinare
cibo da asporto particolarmente costoso
per vedere effettivamente fino a che
punto può arrivare la qualità del
perché lo sto facendo perché volevo una
scusa per mangiare e siccome
teoricamente serial dieta questo è
l'unico a saperlo fare
vi presento il mio alleato di oggi
voglio vedere se effettivamente si può
vivere una giornata la fascia stando
comodamente col culo a casa sushi bari e
foggia piccola postilla questo video non
è sponsorizzato alle app che vedete sono
le app che uso di solito o up che voglio
provare così per evitare qualsiasi tipo
di fraintendimento
una macchia 22 euro per un carpaccio di
gamberi rossi 22 euro per questo muro 22
europee non riempire rule 10 euro e 50
per una tartare di salmone delivery fi 4
euro e 49 di 80 euro e 99 non so nemmeno
se li ho mai speso un ristorante pare
che spendi 80 euro per mangiare tanta
euro per mangiare ragazzi 80 euro per
mangiare un carpaccio 2 ora ma chi da
una tartare pence pero di port in
elicottero il po mi sento uno stronzo
pronto primo piano a destra alla fine
del corridoio arrivo subito a mille
ciao un lavoro si gusta di carte bravi
allora
questo tempo possa credere voglio vedere
che cosa mi hanno portato in carpaccio
di gambero rosso un gambero rosso una
tartare di tonno roll
un'altra norma tele sta sfondando
ragazze pesce crudo sushi moduli soia
zenzero e guardi prima critica troppa
troppa troppa troppa troppa troppa
interminabile troppa plastica non esiste
tipo qua abbiamo un contenitore di
plastica per le cosine di plastica tra
stica plastica l'ustica plastica 80 euro
e tutto quanto in plastica no questo
bruciato viviamo il sapore al carpaccio
che se mettiamo la salsina sopra sembra
un cuore che urla con la pietra di
fantaghirò proviamo la un'altra cosa
poi gioco questo qui cala capasanta
pesce bianco e gambero l'ho sempre
gambero capo santa mangiamo bello
mangiare meglio mangiare piccolo
feedback post pranzo i cifra buonissimo
sarò sincero nei voglio vederci
80 euro 80 euro 80 euro 80 euro 80 euro
ma la qualità comunque molto molto alta
da ristorante nel quale paga
effettivamente quelle cifre lati
negativi
troppa plastica troppa troppa troppa
plastica assolutamente immotivata il
costo non lo metto tre lati negativi
perché comunque ho deciso io di spendere
così tanto per avere questo tipo di
esperienza però ovviamente l'esperienza
a casa il pane mezza tristezza al già mi
sono rotto le palle 80 euro 80 euro 80
euro 80 euro 80 euro
io sto cercando solamente esperienze
dove mi tratto molto bene prevedere
quanto puoi a casa sentirsi comunque una
regina
voglio una corona una norma costruisci
il tuo nachos voglia di costruire non
c'era voglia di maglia secondo me allora
voglio un naso grande pollo bacon pool
porc ragucci di con carne caramella
dalla penna aggiornerà i peperoni che
vendita di funghi panna acida waka mole
11 euro di nasos women and nash alla
nutella mini rings onses tanto ordino
questi quindi per guardarci il film la
cosa più folle che se uno veramente
volesse avesse la disponibilità
economica potrebbe usciva di casa primo
piano ciao maggio grazie già c'è un
cuoricino grazie mille guglielmo buona
giornata anna karina grazie mille
l'impatto il momento di guardarsi né
insieme con questi smith in carta questa
qui e plastica per caso questa è la
plastica da citiamo comodi i più visti
su netflix o voce dell'omosessualità
vedo dai ragazzi ma non dimenticate le
cifre che io assaggerò per te inizia a
fare il primo assaggio lo mangiava la
rete meglio mangiare pure si la facciamo
a dassino gli occhi nachos eccellenti
manco fatti vedere questa è la fine e
poi vorrei dire un'altra mamma tu sei
svuotando i polsi dentro il coso
esperienza di naso a casa davanti alla
televisione per me batte pop corn al
cinema tornatore 18 e pavesi che cosa
dice che bisognerebbe mangiare più
verdura sono del parere che la frenata
della comodità a letto tutti parola
buona per quanti giorni potrà io un
posto impazzendo rimanere a casa
sì ma che schifo ma li mette dentro una
cittadina ci si pensi schierato secondi
fa e non li mangio grazie
pronto primo piano in fondo a destra per
prendere la mancia che se veramente
questi qui sono pagati poco non è giusto
poveri
grazie mille bravo grazie cara preso a
marciare questo bel ragazzo schietto al
suo carico all'anguria e perché gli
diedero usciti dai riprendiamo vedere
una chiesa o lo sai qual'è la cosa
veramente l'impietosa dovrei di sting in
una breve dobbiamo dire la cena ma io
questo possiamo aspettare troppo cosa si
può fare un paio d'ore a chi gli domanda
stupida storia dominare non ce la faccio
più può essere viziata che spesso era il
momento della cena leggera ma costosa
chi piace un'idea vorresti della buona
carne con l'esperienza come sottoporre
tua argentina barbecue state don quando
c'è la vita di mio papà mi ci porta
sempre con sé a milano che ha propri
grazie io vengo da t bone e la nostra
costa di più ma hanno del recco è fatto
apposta questo video è che si appara che
ordina così fa col cellulare mentre
butta soldi è un esperimento per capire
quanto la tua esperienza a casa può
arrivare effettivamente essere luxley ok
questo letto ben poco ho sentito di
quart'ordine il mio letto è una reggia
altri diciamo ci chiami dacia ci
dormiamo senti poi un contorno abbiamo
una ver papa street a papà sala forno o
reti hsdpa papa passa alla pari a papà
stalla papa
di spinaci non s'è rotto ripieno di
formaggio pomodori basilico alzo che tu
sia già un panzerotto di piero
dell'impossibile chi dolce sapore
stiviere pronto primo piano in fondo a
destra leggera ma costosa preso due
mucche esagerato leggera acque un posto
pazzesco questo andrà di fano leggera lo
so ancora mentre leggera le patate
quelle di cole che fu leggera
dell'utilità si va in scena vai voglio
sentirne la tua review sulla carne
soprattutto fatto che è rinato non è
male però considerando che avranno
investito chissà quante di sosta vista e
questo investono chiunque lo mangiavano
rete meglio mangiare e boccassi parlare
di ciclisti che mettono il paziente è
una cosa positiva dello stare a casa che
puoi fare questa roba qui senza sentirti
né colpa ma rai un osso non è un filo
interdentale capisca rilassatezza di
casa reggio della carne buonissima
pensionati sono mamma è tutto molto
molto buono ma al contrario di oggi a
pranzo comincia a pesarmi stare a casa è
buono ma non è all'altezza dell'uscita è
arrivato il momento di fare un'analisi
di quanto è stato speso oggi è un
pochino di tutto quello che è successo
quindi partiamo dalle basi per poter
passare l'intera giornata a casa e fare
diciamo colazione pranzo spuntino e cena
da fare abbiamo speso un po speso la
colazione 22 euro e 50 il pranzo è
venuto 80 euro come dimenticarli e 99 lo
spuntino nachos con le caccia bobolin 18
euro e 90 minchia più le caramelle
salute 12 euro e 90
caramelle viene loro la cena 109 euro e
49 un totale di 244 euro e 78 un paio di
considerazioni di pro
abbiamo sicuramente la comodità il fatto
che effettivamente il cibo è buono
sicuramente arrivo un pochino più
tiepido in alcuni casi specialmente nel
caso della carne nel caso di quei cibi
che sono più buoni espressi proprio
mangiare letto lo puoi mangiare come ti
pare ma incontro sono che un'intera
giornata passata a casa a me
personalmente uccida e veloce di casa è
bello stare con gli amici e ballando in
un ristorante ed è bello anche il brusio
delle persone che ti stanno a fianco e
che ti fanno ricordare di essere un
abitante di tenuta terra costa in
maniera eccessiva nel senso che comunque
c'è sempre una commissione da applicare
a tutto quello che ordini e se calcoli
che sono 3 euro e 50 più 2 euro e 2 euro
3 ore e cinquantadue uffici per pagare
16 euro sono solo di commissione i
packaging secondo me inquinano ok che a
maggior parte sono buste di carta ma la
presenza comunque di plastica
contenitori di plastica sono gli sprechi
nuti di quello che baratti è la comodità
per un pezzettino di qualità e alla fine
questa giornata possa dire che non se la
pena soprattutto a livello di sanità
mentale non ce la faccio più a stare
dentro questa casa con tutto l'affetto
del mondo ho bisogno di uscire di fare
un giro anche solo per prendere una
bottiglietta d'acqua che sempre plastica
attaccarmi una fontana bere con una
lunghissima cannuccia di vetro acqua dal
naviglio quindi personalmente come
esperienza per quanto divertente per
quanto simpatica io la boccio
completamente